حرب عالميه يتعرض لها تطبيق تيك توك
الصينيه الذي بات يشكل تحديا كبيرا
للحكومه الامريكيه التي تسعى لتقييده
وحظره بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي
مساعي الحظر قابلها تزايد شعبيه تيك توك
في الولايات المتحده رغم ان واشنطن كشفت
عن تتبع التطبيق لعشرات المواقع الحكوميه
والتجسس عليها وفق صحيفه وولد جورنال حيث
اصبح تيك توك من اكثر تطبيقات الهواتف
الذكيه الشعبيه في البلاد لدى الملايين من
الاشخاص والشركات وفق تقرير صادر عن موقع
اكسيوس الامريكي فالشركه لديها الان اكثر
من 150 مليون مستخدم في الولايات المتحده
اي ما يقرب من نصف عدد السكان في حين ان 5
ملايين شركه امريكيه تستخدم تطبيق تيك توك
للوصول الى عملائها ومن المتوقع ان يح
التطبيق اكثر من 11 مليار دولار من عائدات
الاعلانات في الولايات المتحده بحلول عام
وفي انتظار مستقبل التطبيق الذي اطلقته
الصين في عام 2016
المشرعون الذين يعارضون الحظر يطالبون
الحكومه بايجاد دليل اكثر اقناعا على ان
التيك توك يمثل تهديدا للامن القومي في
حين يقول المشرعون الذين يدعمون التحركات
ضد تيك توك ان التطبيق يمثل تهديدا
لخصوصيه بيانات المستخدم في الولايات
المتحده بسبب القوانين الصينيه التي تطلب
من الشركات مشاركه بيانات المستخدم مع
الحكومه الصينيه